You guys are in my way
It’s fine!
Keep your head down
There you go!
Wow!
Today we are teaming up with
the amazing juggler Josh Horton
Our plan is to create as many tricks
as possible in only five hours
Oh my gosh!
The clock starts now
First trickshot of the day
First try?
Yeah, first try
Alright, incoming!
Alright!
Oh geez!
Actually, let’s move the table
against the black curtain
Now the setup is perfect
so now it will be first try
Here we go!
Incoming!
Ready!
There we have it!
Smooth!
Nice!
Like we’ve been doing it for years
Yeah!
Now, let’s try to keep it going
like a continuous cycle
Oh yeah!
That’s easy!
Okay!
Yeah!
We can go on forever
Nice!
Sweet!
Already two in the bag
Playing while juggling
I’m going to beat you
Okay!
Maybe not
Josh!
I always get mad
When I can’t do stuff
I’ve never done before
Nice!
Keep going!
Oh my god!
That’s so impressive!
What!?
Yes!
That was good
That was so sick
I really didn’t expect that to be possible
This is what I’m currently able to do
And also switch like this
Not bad!
Right, left, right, left
Go for four catches
I need one more hand to do this
Now stop!
I was going to stop
There should be a big ol’ gap
right here
Yeah!
But you are getting the gap
all cluttered up
Yeah!
Let’s go!
I am the best coach ever
I just came up with a trick we can do
Do the spin
The ball goes through on that side
and the comes back on the other
That’s actually a good one
Oooh!
Almost first try
My gosh!
He went through, not back
Yeah!
Come on!
Ooh!
It would be a lot easier
if the ring could come all the way here
and then back
No!
This somehow looks so satisfying
And the sound is so nice on the table
Oh my gosh!
Let’s go!
Nice!
I can’t believe we got that
That was so good!
You were like:
“This would be easy”
I was like: “There’s no way!”
I actually didn’t believe
that it’s possible at all
but that’s how you do it
One!
In the lens!
Actually pass them quite quickly
after each other
More likely to fall over like that
That’s probably true
One
Two
Oh, sorry!
Sorry Sensei!
Straight in the face
Completely brand new Sensei racket
One
Two
Three
Let’s go!
Nice!
Well done!
2:35 left
Time for some spooning?
Yes!
This is one of my favorite tricks
Spoons in the cups
You focus on
that spoon and that cup
And that’s it
First try
I’m going to say like 26 tries
26?
Nine tries
Really close
Definitely higher than we just did
You got one!
Yeah!
Ooh!
Four out of five
This is the one
Let’s go!
It’s a very satisfying trick
Thanks!
Hold on
Ready?
Yup!
Oh!
That’s actually very hard to do
It’s my turn
Yeah!
Ooh!
It touched it
It hit the rim!
No!
There it is!
Yes!
My neck hurts
I need a massage
Ready
Set
Go!
I missed my own ball
Three
Two
One
There we have it
Yeah!
Emil was checking like:
“Were they all in?”
Anyone missed?
No one missed?
Nobody missed, yeah!
Wooh!
Nice!
Alright, are we ready?
Go!
That tempo would be good
if we can get it
That’s pretty tough
More balls?
Yeah!
Go!
That was nice
Confusing but impressive
I’m going to teach you
how to do a 360
Throwing three up looks like that
But we are going work on a 1-up 360
So one up, turn around
and continue juggling
It’ll be best if you throw
your high throw with your left hand
and you catch it in your right hand
That wasn’t bad
Not bad
You were still doing a little bit of this
which will make you really dizzy
No!
That was nice!
Geez!
Why are you squatting?
Watch out!
There you go
That was nice!
Let’s go!
Nice!
Yes!
That was it
Now you are going to do
all three up and two spins
Okay, I’ve got it
One, two, three!
Almost!
Try to throw that it’s above your head
Yeah, it will be this high
And watch directly to the camera
And I’ll go like...
Okay!
Like that
Geez!
Yeah!
That’s better
Ready?
Alright!
We got it!
Woah!
That was the orange one
That was it!
Alright, we got it
That was clean
We throw you one
and then you just knock it in
Does it have water in it?
It’s saliva but yes
Coming!
Geez!
That’s it!
Oh, that felt good
Wow!
Get in!
Oh my gosh!
Coming!
Let’s go!
Look at that!
One
Two
Three
Four
And toss
Yeah!
That’s really good
And then you’ll do one slow lob
that goes through the pass
Hopefully we’ll have time
Not the easiest one
This one either
Let’s just go once through the hoops
and then we play the point to the end
Three
Two
One
That was...
Alright!
Now it’s time
Three
Two
One
That was it!
Was it?
100%
That was it
Yeah, it was
I actually stopped playing there
because I thought we screwed that up
I feel like all the times
you guys said: “One”
I was like: “I don’t know”
but that one I know was both
Make sure to subscribe to both channels
and let us know
who should be our next challenger
Until next time